bom dia
deve ser meio antagônico pensar que uma
pessoa que não tem 100% do movimento
corporal aqui falando num toque sobre
movimento não é pois bem eu vou mostrar
que exigem que existem outras formas de
fazer movimento
na verdade eu já cheguei movimentando a
minha família eu nasci no meio de um
feriado na madrugada ea maioria achava
que eu era menino
fazer o que né
eu tinha uma deficiência de nascimento
que é pela medicina chamada de paralisia
cerebral mas eu carinhosamente digo que
é minha mão direita é uma excelente
carregadora de bolsas imaginem um charme
que não vi que na infância por não poder
brincar de pega-pega esconde-esconde eu
tive que é que lidar com uma habilidade
muito boa de falar em microfone
acho que é por isso que eu estou aqui
hoje na adolescência quem aqui não teve
aqueles questionamento por que eu não me
dou bem com o meu corpo não é o meu foi
porque eu não podia assalto por aí na
balada ou tinha aqui com uma scooter
assim foi no meio desses questionamentos
que eu conheci a mara gabrilli que
representa as pessoas com deficiência no
comitê sobre citou emaná onu
na hora de fazer um intercâmbio
acreditem foi a primeira vez que eu
atravessei a rua na vida isso é uma
emoção gigante na hora que eu voltei
para o brasil essas atravessados de rua
lá o meu tombo e fizeram cair ter alguns
insights
eu comecei a pensar e se estiver fazendo
um bolo e mel açúcar acabar eu não
consigo pedi para o meu vizinho
infelizmente não porque no brasil cada
um é responsável pela sua calçada seja
pararam pra pensar nessa
responsabilidade ou então querer na
padoca comprar um pão
foi então que buscando através da rua
aqui no meu país eu resolvi começar a
pesquisar sobre o assunto e aí quando se
falava de pessoas com deficiência eu
percebia que tudo era frio era gelado se
valorizavam
muito mais essa cadeira aquela bengala
de quem tem deficiência visual
esqueciam do ser humano que estava ali e
foi então que eu resolvi criar o meu
blog mas eu falo dele mais tarde ele eu
resolvi também quando como eu viajei
muito para os estados unidos
resolvi testar que estava chegando
mundial aqui no brasil eu resolvi está
como estava os aeroportos pra receberem
essas pessoas vamos dar uma olhadinha
[Música]
i aeroporto de uma das maiores
metrópoles do brasil em 15 minutos nós
pegamos três carros estacionado na vaga
de deficiente incluindo 2 a 1
[Música]
[Aplausos]
é hora
[Música]
a cadeira de rodas moça a não pode não
pode
ae
[Música]
olha
[Aplausos]
[Música]
foi então criando um blog que eu tive
vários outros 20 sites
eu reparei que quando eu ia pra mídia
falada sempre passava aquela coisa ele
trabalha ele estuda e é deficiente e eu
me sentia uma capinha de super-heroína
sabe quando ouve essas coisas
então eu resolvi escrever a minha
biografia e contar que apesar de tudo
isso a gente também é feliz também tem
sonhos e não precisa da capa de
super-herói foi dentro dessas buscas que
eu também enxerguei e daí eu quero
convidar vocês a fazerem uma reflexão
junto comigo que a maioria de nós é
sempre procuro olhar para o que é ruim
para o que falta então foi aí que dentro
da palavra deficiência
pra mim eu vejo a palavra eficiência eu
comecei a valorizar o que era bom e
dentro da cada não que foi dado pra mim
eu comecei a prestar atenção que no
inglês noel era new opportunity era uma
oportunidade de mostrar que era
diferente então quando eu comecei a ter
um blog e deletar meu projeto via da
palestra pessoas falavam nossa você é
tão linda tão inteligente pena que é
deficiente
eu fico furiosa com isso eu não entendo
e aí foi então uma hora que eu resolvi
deixar que as pessoas não fizessem mais
movimentos por mim eu abandonei a
fisioterapia e resolvi e pra academia
criar rashtag definidas
acreditem funciona deficiência com
academia e aí eu também tenho mais um
questionamento para vocês porque eu
defino eu buscava mostrar para as
pessoas nas redes sociais o que trazia
bem estar e você como está cuidando do
bem estar na sua vida
e antes de terminar a minha fala eu
gostaria de perguntar pra vocês quem
mora na paulista por favor não responde
essa minha pergunta se não estraga como
é a calçada da vida de vocês da casa de
vocês como que é para uma pessoa
o andar de salto em são paulo como é pra
você andar de carrinho de bebê em são
paulo e passear com vôo com a avó ou até
mesmo para aquele motoqueiro domingo à
noite que você pede a pizza como é pra
chegar na sua casa
é exatamente esse o meu recado eu
gostaria de convidar vocês agora que
saírem daqui olharem para as calçadas e
pensarem por que tudo isso não é só bom
pra mim é bom pra vocês também
obrigada
[Aplausos]